hey I'm Sathya Reva I'm here with
BuzzFeed and I'm talking about my first
times first thing that attracted you to
Harriet the fact that the story had
never been told on the big screen and I
think that it is high time we did tell
her story so that's why I wanted to be a
part of it
who was your first real friend in
Hollywood and do you still speak
remember my first was because I kind of
met everyone at the same time it was
quite a busy couple of years you know
who I was starstruck by gianelle when I
first met her because I was obsessed
with her when I when she first came out
that was like the metropolis album to
those albums and I went to see her in
concert in London when she was in
Shepherds Bush and now we're really good
friends so we're in this movie together
first song you put on when you're having
a bad day I am alight by India Irie I
finish the sentence I want to be the
first person in Hollywood to have opened
a performing arts school that can
communicate both in the UK and here in
the US so it's like interactive that can
be cool tell us about your first time
performing on the West End the color
purple is the first show I did it was
epic and clearly it changed my life
that's why I'm here first celebrity
crush I'm not saying that because first
line that pops into your head when
someone mentions the color purple I
think it makes God mad to see the color
purple and not notice it first time you
bombed an audition I don't think I've
bombed an audition yet have I that I
think so and I'm really not lying I
genuinely don't think I have yet I don't
really want to first person you called
when you won a Tony Award does it count
if you called them out when you're on
the stage if it counts then I called my
mom she was the first person I told well
she's the first much I mentioned she was
there but and then I called my sister
describe your first bad date do I say
that out loud
it was bad he had braces first time you
got turned down for a role you really
wanted was it low easy I didn't really
want it I can't remember what it was
never mind first impressions of Leslie
Odom jr. - nominee and Joe Elrond so
Leslie Odom jr. and I know each other
very well the first time I met him was
at the friend's wedding and I got his
night he's cool very cool he thought I
was a child he actually literally
thought it was like her 12 year old
cousin for some reason apparently I look
young thanks Leslie Jenelle was lovely
really really sweet she was abusive and
kind and funny and I realized that she
was a small of me she's tiny
Joe is extremely tall he's the opposite
very very tall but very sweet and we're
worried about me whilst we were on set
so I was very glad so he was the one
thing opposite me because I knew it
would be taken care of first thing you
tell yourself when you feel like giving
up take a breath you'll be fine get on
with it first time you were starstruck I
mean it's probably when I met Oprah the
first time we were rehearsing the color
purple and actually singing the color
purple with the whole cast it was
towards the end everyone saw her come
into the room and cuz I meet and
stubborn I refused to stop singing so
there is a video for the hugging her and
singing very loudly in her ear because
in my head I was like we are not
stopping this song people we're gonna
sing this song we're gonna do this song
and make everybody proud okay we're
going to a press first item you ever
took from the set a struggle sometimes
they let me take my shoes or an item of
clothing just so it could it reminds me
of a character I don't think I did just
the cards and stuff with people saying
first time you realize you wanted to be
a performer when I was five and it had
been nativity play it was a shepherd let
me sing silent night by myself I liked
how people reacted and I thought if this
makes people happy in but it might as
well continue so that's what I've been
doing trying to make people happy ever
since first funny memory that comes to
mind when you when thinking of the hairy
upset there's nothing particularly funny
there was some really wonderful moments
we tell the story all the time because
it was epic
there's a moment when she steps over
into freedom and the Sun comes out that
day was terrible like the worst day ever
so we get to this this spot where were
supposed to be shooting it the scene
begins with me coming up in a horse and
carriage and the Sun stuff to come up
now mind you it had been raining and
dark all day Sun starts to come up I get
off the buggy and I walk up to the point
and they do a jump and the Sun bursts
out through the clouds it's like orange
and reds and yellows and is blaring at
my face and my face looks amber in in
the film that is not CGI it's not
lighting that's the actual Sun on my
face then I look to the right and
there's a double rainbow a real double
rainbow so that was really cool that's
all thank you for watching be sure to
check out Harriet and November 1st or
theater right now go buy your tickets
they're ours out
bye
[Music]
[Music]